pour moi je pense que c'est nécessaire
de le faire mais encore une fois vous
savez la réponse olympien tout au tout
la personne et des clés avec un regard
devient ensuite des propositions à la
décision ultime effectivement si
vraiment un moment on n'a plus le choix
il faut le faire mais je veux juste
rappeler une chose au premier
confinement les gens à accepter plutôt
la situation est aujourd'hui on peut
dire qu'un état d'épuisement de la
population beaucoup plus important et un
état de violences globale beaucoup plus
important et au premier confinement déjà
on avait ça ce sont des chiffres une
augmentation de 30% des violences sur
les enfants 30%
c'est pas des chiffres c'est des enfants
qui se sont fracassés pourquoi parce que
ces gens qui tapent leurs enfants se
moquent diane leur faire des bleus parce
que le lendemain
personne ne sera là pour les voir et les
femmes une femme sur trois aujourd'hui
qui subit des violences dit avoir subi
des violences la première fois lors du
premier confinement et c'est pour cela
que ce sont des vies
ce sont deux c cessé de sonder 4 concret
on n'est pas en train de parler de payer
les impayés les autres moi j mais je
pense que le devoir de la république
aujourd'hui c'est de maintenir jusqu'au
bout les l'école ouverte parce que c'est
le seul moyen d'avoir un regard sur ces
pauvres enfants qui se font taper sur
ces pauvres femmes pour lesquels c'est
le seul moyen de sortir de la maison et
de pouvoir dire qu'elles se font taper
etc etc
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut pousser
jusqu'au bout et là je rejoins yann moix
a pas que du coup ci il faut savoir
aussi que cette crise ce sont les plus
fragiles qui vont en sortir totalement
fracassée et un enfants qui décrochent
scolairement dans les parents n'ont pas
les moyens
ce n'est sûrement pas le cas de nous
tous aussi sur le plateau mais quand les
parents n'ont pas les moyens plus jamais
cet enfant réalisera ses rêves
et bien pour toutes ces raisons jusqu au
bout battons-nous même si ça fait plus
de co vide il faut l'assumer parce que
c'est en vente nous organisions veillées
et les protégeons notre marque elle
parce qu'il me reste 10 minutes j'ai une
proposition à faire
moi ce qui m'ennuie c'est d'entendre des
andes des arguments comme les vôtres en
faveur du maintien l'école auquel ont
souscrit absolument tout sauf que c'est
déjà trop tard c'est moi mardi soir j'ai
été prévenu à 19h par l'ama commune que
le centre de loisirs du mercredi
n'accueillait pas ma fille de 8 ans qui
est assez loin non ce moment
ce mercredi mais le suivant l'ont
souvent et le sur suivant nous sommes
les amis nous sommes déjà dedans c'est
déjà gêné plutôt que l'enfant soit à
l'interné aurait pas dire d'une part
faut que les enfants soient à l'école
mais que lorsque c'est les enfants de
105 me qui vont pas à l'école parce que
c'est eux qui est immédiatement là tout
petit ont déjà concernés par les
fermetures de classes et les fermetures
de centres d'animation tu fais comme si
ça n'existait pas et tu fais là le
maquereau et et eric ont éclairé
ridicule tout le monde ait bien compris
ce que je voulais un tiers et n'essaye
pas maîtres de la scène sonic 2 play
tous les enfants sont égaux dans la
république
quant au dg de la même famille que la
seine-saint-denis tu ignores le fait que
les écoles personnage assez drôle que
c'est parce que j'en aurai je te laisse
dans ton de vous le dire j'ai entendu ça
mais les écoles ferment déjà arrêté
comme combattre et vaincre est dit il
faut faire des vacances pardon je trouve
ça parfaitement hypocrite moi je ne sont
pas les écoles y est parvenu à faire le
déplacement et je me dis moi tout ce que
vous avez tout fait et pour nous arrive
nous à blida et qu'il faudra faire nous
peut-être ces virus ouvert mais bien sûr
et dans ce cas je dis juste ne laissez
pas les gens en plus dans la misère il y
avait un laboratoire
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît là qui n'est pas un
dialogue c'est cette maladie il faut que
c'est quand même important de le dire
cette maladie elle touche les gens de
façon inégale selon à cause du g10
excuse marqué d'accord voilà lady
sociale également visé pour ça que des
gens demandent qu'en seine saint denis
ya peut-être une expérience pilote où on
vaccine non seulement les enseignants
mais les premiers de corvée d'accord
parce que c'est aussi une réalité si
vous voulez que les écoles restent
ouvertes
il vous faut que les atsem il vous faut
que les hostilités ou faut que les profs
que tel équipement voiture et compagnie
vous conduire dans l' endroit à l'autre
de l'île de france
a la ratp où les autres il faut que ces
gens là puissent ne pas attraper le coc
vide donc moi je
et je demande une expérience pilote
peut-être qu'il faut pas commencer par
vacciner partout en france les personnes
de 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans mais je vous en
supplie si vous êtes sérieux sur votre
journée vernement pour les enfants à
l'école dame enceinte sa gueule
d'actionner les premiers de corvée
d'accéder dans l'ensemble saint géry